one problem 120
120.
david has d books which is three times
as many as jeff
so d
books is three times as many as jeff
and one half as many as paula so d
is equal to one-half the number of books
paula has
how many books do the three of them have
together in terms of d
okay so they want to know how much d
plus j
plus p is in terms of d
so what's j in terms of d
j is equal to divide both sides by three
is equal to d over three and what's p in
terms of d
p is equal to if we multiply both sides
by 2 you get p is equal to 2 d
so this turns into d plus j which is d
over 3
d over 3
plus p which is 2d
which is equal to let's find a common
denominator well 3.
1 d is the same thing as
3 d over 3
d over 3 well that's still just going to
be d over three d over three
two d over two d that's the same thing
as six d over three six d over three
that's equal to let's see three
four
plus six is ten d
10 d over 3 or 10 thirds d
and that's choice c
10 thirds d is choice
c
problem 121
121 there are eight teams in a certain
league and each team plays each of the
other teams exactly once
fair enough eight teams and they each
play each other each exactly once if
each game is played by two teams
fair enough it's a traditional game what
is the total number of games played
total number of games played
okay so let's think about it a little
bit
let's think about it they each play each
other exactly once
so this this turns into that grid
problem that we did last time because
think about it
if i have eight teams so let's see one
two three
four five six
seven eight
and i'm gonna write the same team one
two three sorry three
four five six
six
seven eight
they can't play each other so none of
you know one's never going to play one
two is never gonna play two three is
never going to play three four is never
gonna play four and etc all the way down
the diagonal you can't play yourself
and one's going to play two exactly one
game
right that's one game and we're not
going to write two played one because
one already played two right they only
play each other once so you don't want
to count
this one down here
you don't want to count this one
this is when one plays three this is
when two plays three so essentially you
want to figure out all of these spots
that are above the diagonal
let's think about how many spots there
are first of all how many total spots
there are if we have an eight by eight
square
there are eight times eight
you could you could say squares on this
grid if i actually drew them as squares
i did that in
a couple of problems ago if i actually
drew it like that
you would have and then you might you
might see the grid a little bit better
but i think you get the idea you have
eight by eight spots on this grid right
because there's eight spots it's eight
spots high eight spots wide so you have
64 spots
now you're not going to have one of the
games along the diagonal because that
would be a team playing itself so how
many spots are along the diagonal well
there's eight right there's one against
one two and two three and three so
that's each team playing itself so
there's eight spots along the diagonal
so 64
minus eight
is 56
56 and so 56 would give us a number of
squares that aren't in the diagonal but
if we counted all of them we would be
double counting we would be counting
that we play we'd be counting one
playing two up here and two playing one
right so we only want to count half of
the remaining squares so if you divide
this by 2
you get 28. so there'd be a total of 28
games and that's choice
c
question 122
an operation theta is defined by the
equation
a
theta b
is equal to
a minus b
over a plus b
for all numbers a and b such that
a does not equal minus b that ensures
that the denominator does not equal zero
so they're defining the domain if a
equal minus b then it would be undefined
because you'd have something divided by
zero
if a does not equal negative c so they
tell us if
a
does not equal minus c
and a
theta c is equal to zero
then c is equal to
okay fair enough so they're telling us
right now that a does not equal
minus c so if so let's just write it
down a theta c
a theta c
is equal to
a minus c right
over a plus c
and then that we want to set equal to
zero because they're telling us a theta
c is equal to zero
right
they're telling us
that a does not equal minus c so they're
telling us that a does not equal minus c
so they're that's essentially saying
because if a was minus c then the
denominator would be zero and we'd have
something really strange so they're
telling us the denominator does not
equal 0.
so if the denominator is not equal 0 and
this fraction equals 0 then the
numerator of this fraction has to be
equal to 0. or another way you could say
it you could say a minus c over a plus c
is equal to zero we know a plus c is not
equal to zero so let's multiply both
sides of the equation times it
and you get a minus c is equal to zero
times a plus c well that's just zero
another way of saying i mean if a
fraction is equal to zero the
denominator is not zero that'll make it
undefined then the numerator has to be
equal zero
so then just solving you get a is equal
to c
right add c to both sides so they want
to know what c is equal to so c is equal
to a
and that is choice e
next question
let me switch colors
123.
the price of a lunch for 15 people
was 207 dollars price for
was two hundred and seven dollars
including a fifteen percent gratuity for
service so that was plus fifteen percent
what was the average price per person
excluding
excluding the gratuity
okay so essentially
we want to figure out
so this is the price
so price before
price of 15
before gratuity
times
so this is after gratuity so i'll call
this price before gratuity i want to get
too complicated with my notation price
but for gratuity
times
1.15 right because we're going to
increase by 15 is equal to 207 dollars
right
and we want to we want to figure out so
the price before gratuity
of the 15 people is equal to 207
divided by 1.15
and we want to figure out the average
price per person so we want to figure
out this divided by 15
so we want to figure out that
divided by
that divided by
15.
okay well this looks
at at its heart kind of kind of mathy
but we'll you know looks like we have to
do a lot of let's just chug through it
and see where we can go
so this is the same thing as
times 1.15
times
1 over 15
and that's equal to let's maybe we
should that's equal to 207
divided by 15 times 1.15
denominator
let's figure out the denominator first
so well maybe the numerator will let's
let's do 207 divided by 1.15 maybe
that'll
one
1.15
goes into
add some decimals
push this 2 to the right 2 to the right
decimal goes there
115 goes into 207 one time 1 times 115
is 115
and then let's see it's 85 plus 7
right to go 85 plus 7 is
and twenty
and then this should go
roughly
eight times
eight times one fifteen
is eight times five is forty
eight times one is eight plus four is
twelve
carry the one eight times one is eight
plus one is nine oh it actually actually
was exactly 9 20. great
okay let me make sure that i
so before gratuity it was 180
so
before gratuity our price was 180 and
now we have to divide that by 15 to get
the average price
so 15 goes into 180 how many times 1
times 15
30 15 goes into 30 two times so the
average price before gratuity was
exactly twelve dollars
b
and i'm out of time see in the next
video